watch this one here's the televised
mental institution known as MSNBC and
Joe good old Joe Scarborough he's very
you know it's hot it's you're not going
to believe this it's hot right now in
certain parts of America we're rolling
into August we're at the end of July
that's known uh I'm not a scientist but
I believe we call that summer it's one
of the Four Seasons I'm not talking
about Frankie Valli in the Four Seasons
I'm talking about the actual Four
Seasons uh and it's hot right now and
Joe's freaking out because it's warm
yeah I mean it's getting harder and
harder to fly this summer really tough
because of of of of the extraordinary uh
weather crisis that is gripping the
country uh causing flights to be
canceled left and right uh headline out
of Las Vegas Delta flight canceled when
heat related illnesses hit passengers
headed from Las Vegas to Atlanta
108 degrees outside four hours on the
tarmac and people inside the airplane
suffering uh he heat related illnesses
it is again I mean and you you look at
the storms you look at the disasters and
if you're if if you're still denying uh
the impact of climate change and the
impact of billions and billions of
Americans uh pumping uh carbon into the
atmosphere non-stop China and India
especially right now but also the United
States disproportionately doing the same
you you're you're you're living in an
alternate reality yes Joe I am living in
an alternate reality than you because
you live in Bizarro Progressive cycle
land and I live on planet Earth
everything you just said there of course
everything you just said was completely
nonsense it's hot let me get this
straight it's hot in Las Vegas at the
end of July it got into the hundreds in
Vegas in the end of July the plane that
he's referring to is because the air
conditioning broke on the plane that
does happen on planes every now and
again I I'm guaranteeing almost
everybody watching this has been on a
Lane where they've had an air
conditioning problem it does happen
every now and again and people are
saying it's very hot in Arizona right
now that's been a thing it's very hot in
Arizona uh Connor you are from Phoenix
can you tell me as a as an arizonan
growing up there you're a young kid
you're out there on your bike in the
summer but how would you describe the
weather and this is you know you're in
your 30s so this is a while ago
you don't go Outdoors he's saying it's
warm it was warm when he was a child
growing up in the summer in Arizona do
you understand this and that this Joe
and you billions of Americans with your
carbon and your fossil fuels and it's
like all of us could shut down all of
our cars and our gas stoves and we could
sit underground eating goo and China and
India would actually still be pumping
all that crap into the into the
atmosphere that's how it works people
[Music]
oh